it was a study conducted by four
universities here in the uk and it was
found that for every 16 point increase
for a man in iq his prospect of marriage
increases by 35
but for every 16 point increase in a
woman's iq her prospect of marriage
decreases by 40 percent
vincent harnam welcome to the show
chris thanks for having me buddy really
appreciate it my pleasure man so
your writing is some of the favorite
stuff that i've read on the internet
over the last couple of years you don't
write regularly but the stuff that you
put out is bomb however what you do
during the day you're like a like a
hyper nerd by day
and then you write about
social dynamics and trends and dating
and culture and stuff
talk to me about how those two things
blend together
okay well one correction there i'm not a
hyper nerd i'm a hyper geek okay
there's a slight difference between no
don't apologize don't fall it's like
this this typology that i've created to
separate geeks dorks and nerds what's
the difference we can talk okay so i've
i've um
i've came i've come to the conclusion
that in order to be one of these things
you have to have or don't have to have
either intellectualism or functional
utility so a geek is a person that has
is that is intellectual but also has a
level of function utility so a coder for
example does something which which
actually helps people but there's some
intellectual rigor required there a nerd
has intellectualism but lacks functional
utility so reading a book on 14th
century poetry doesn't really help a lot
of people right there's no societal
benefit to that sort of thing and a dork
has neither
not a functional utility nor
intellectualism
all right so that's the matrices that
you've put together that uh explains the
what would you say the computerly
inclined uh
modern poetically inclined yeah okay
okay cool right so talk to me what's
this
marriage between these two worlds
well
for me i
all the articles that i write i do in my
free time it's not something that i
think about necessarily on a daily basis
or i even do for my day job so what i do
is that i i maybe i have an interest in
idea or something that i want to pursue
further and then i accumulate as much
data as i can and i apply the sort of
research skills that i have as a data
scientist uh the data analyst and i
tried to take a complex idea and then
simplify it as much as i can so papers
on white privilege
sexual dynamics or simping these are all
things i think people find interesting
but there isn't really any empirical
rigor behind any of it and so my job i
think as as an intellectual per se or a
person that that does data analysis is
to try to break it down such that people
understand it in a cogent way
this gets around the
sort of armchair philosophizing excuse
that a lot of people have with this
right they just sit and throw cod
psychology bro science out there i mean
like this is me down to a t
and
yet you have somebody that can come in
with some hard data and actually back
that up or refute it
yes correct the problem with the
cultural words as i see it is that
nothing is actually empirical so they'll
state that uh get will go broke is a
principle by which these companies
operate under but in actuality when i
when i crunch the numbers it wasn't the
case right these companies weren't
actually losing money's money if they if
they engage in any sort of capitalism or
if they pander to the hard left
and i wonder how much of all these
concepts that people espouse in the
culture wars
are true and how many of them need to be
back tested or just tested in general
yeah so you're able to stress test these
with actual data because they sound go
get woke go broke or whatever sounds i
mean it rhymes
like that's powerful it's it's a meme
that's why it's so popular it's a it's a
damn meme and if if anything is mimified
it becomes popular so something like
dogecoin which has no basic fundamentals
is incredibly popular because it is a
meme it's a dog it's it's doge
well yeah okay so
get what go broke is like dogecoin but
for culture was
sure yeah sure we could say that yeah
okay um but you studied the dark web as
well right you've done investigations
into that yes you've done a bit of
research my friend i like it yeah so my
uh my phd thesis was on the dark web so
i looked at transactional networks on
the dark web and tried to identify well
really how they operated what the
structural vulnerabilities were and then
the idea was sort of to come up with a a
dossier of strategies that law
enforcement uh organizations could could
actually use to take these uh these
entities down it makes
makes complete sense going from dark web
to learning about simping
the perfect just the perfect logical
consistency between those two things
correct so what did you learn about
simping then
well
that it doesn't work that it's it's if
one wants to engage with women and get
into a meaningful relationship simping
is not the way forward because you're
basically
you're placating right you're you're a
pliable male that's trying to appeal to
females and you're not actually engaging
with them on an emotional level you're
just giving them presents and undo
compliments and these women are
essentially using you for your resources
fundamentally i don't really blame them
right if if if you throw a fastball down
the middle of the plate you're gonna hit
it are you not
so the same thing applies here i guess
okay what for the people that don't know
the term how would you describe what
simp is well a simp so the etymology of
the term actually goes back i think to
the 1920s where simp was a shortened or
condensed version of the term simpleton
uh but it was actually
it was it was taken by rappers the 1980s
1990s and using a couple of rap songs
uh i forget which one was it i think
maybe tupac or biggie had a song where
they use the term percent but in in
modern parlors simp is a term that is
used to describe a man that is you know
romantically hapless right he sort of
gives presents and praise to women with
the expectation of receiving some sort
of sexual or emotional ratification
but receives none of it because he's
he's pliable right he doesn't actually
bring anything to the table emotionally
or
really in terms of being a worthwhile
partner to have
yeah and only fans has basically
monetized and weaponized this right yes
audi fans is the industrialization of
simping that's that's basically how i
would define it and it's look it's a
fantastic business model like if we were
to look at it purely from from the lens
of of a business perspective it is
excellent and what it does because it
capitalizes on something which is
endemic today in the sexual marketplace
and that's that's emotional that's this
emotional connection that young men
desire
yes and they
the asymmetry the fact that most men
fear rejection that they struggle with
finding a mate
means that if they can pay to remove
rejection
even if they know that the chance of
genuine reciprocation is basically zero
most men are happy to pay that price
absolutely absolutely they're more than
happy to pay
and i think that probably speaks more
about the nature and quality of men
today than it does about anything else
that you would forego any sort of
hardship for an easy win or an easy win
in their mind it's like video games
right i'm not knocking anyone that
necessarily plays video games but the
notion that the trophy that you'd win in
a video game is that about or similar to
a you know winning a physical trophy in
a sports competition are the same is is
nonsensical and the same thing applies
here that you're foregoing rejection for
what seems like emotional and emotional
connection with a woman that you don't
really know
i see this in the personal development
world as well so a lot of people if you
look at linkedin profiles and that data
analysis of linkedin profiles found that
strategizing was one of the most used
words in all strategizing our strategy
most used words in all of descriptions
and yet executing or executor wasn't
even in the top 100 reason for that
being that it is significantly easier to
strategize and execute because by always
strategizing and never executing you
prevent yourself from potential failure
by inoculating yourself from success
if i just speak rhetorically
there's no chance that i'm going to fail
because in my world in the world that i
create of words that never actually
needs to come up against reality
you're completely correct i don't
disagree with that at all i mean action
wins the day right as that saying goes
and you know everyone has a platter
excuse me everyone has a dream but no
one has a plan and it's not only having
a plan it's executing the plan right we
can talk as much as we want about things
we want to do you know a girl we like to
talk to and get into a relationship of
business we would like to start but if
you don't put one foot in front of the
other and start marching forward and
actually taking the necessary step
towards achieving those things you're
never going to achieve it
why do you think there is a current
trend amongst men
towards this easier
route out whether that be in video games
or in dating
it's a good question and it's a complex
question which means that the answer is
probably multivariate in the sense that
there's no simple answer one one
variable which explains why it is that
men are that are the way they are uh in
this sense it's it's probably has to do
with socialization uh how men are
socialized uh today uh maybe coddling as
well the sort of parenting
uh strategies that uh that are used to
raise young boys and rear them um
it's it's a good question but i would
say those are probably the two things
that i would i would probably point to
that we sort of bred out the warrior
aspect the uh sort of frontiersman
notion in men right that that notion of
going out there and getting after it's
been bred out of a lot of men and
we're sort of
afraid or
hesitant to engage in things which make
us uncomfortable
and i think david goggins actually who
is a personal hero of mine he talks
about it in terms of suffering that
beyond suffering lies greatness
but in order to achieve greatness you
first have to suffer and people are just
terrified of discomfort and suffering
which you know they're they're scary
things yes but
if you want to be where you want to be
you're going to have to suffer right
you're going to have to uh you know to
pay the price not only is this happening
on an individual level but you've also
got a cultural level of this with
regards to the views around masculinity
men overall what the definition of a man
is
yes yes that's a curious thing actually
i want to ask you about that
specifically how you would define
what what a man is or what it means to
be a man okay well i'm going to uh go
back to our mutual friend uh rob
henderson because he
he recently posted
uh a stat
on one of his newsletters and again like
this is if if anyone's playing [ __ ]
rob henderson bingo at home
um because they should be uh i brought
uh rory sutherland on the show and he's
one of the smartest behavioral
economists on the planet and he said
that uh
he was in awe of rob henderson um yeah
where is it so he said that there was
three things that all men needed to do
and it was something like um always be
in control
always show competence
and something else i mean the
definitions around masculinity and what
it means to be a man
you're trying to encapsulate
a felt sense and an embodied sense
lexically which is always going to be a
mess right because the words are always
going to be slightly imprecise and
because we're looking for
generalizations here people are always
going to be able to point out
aberrations of the generalization um
but overall i i think i agree i can't
find the particular quote um but
i think i agree it's to do with a
competency a control of oneself and
one's own emotions
um
leadership from the front taking
responsibility
um you know these things
whether you're a man or a woman a
masculine man or a masculine woman i
think that anybody that embodies those
traits you would say yeah that's you
know that's a fairly masculine way to be
i like that and i completely agree with
it so jack donovan who is um i don't
really know what you would call it maybe
you've heard of it or read some of his
books
he um he's a fascinating figure i think
because he writes on masculinity and uh
two books in particular that i've read
of his um
the tribe and the way of men and he
states that masculinity is a combination
of four things so we have honor you have
strength you have courage and you have
mastery and i like those but in my mind
i have a tripartite model as well so i
would say that it's based around um
courage which i think he's right so
being afraid of doing something but then
doing it anyway
uh the second which relates to something
you said is personal responsibility
verging on extreme ownership and extreme
ownership is a term that is is used um
by jocko willing so taking taking
control not only of the things within
your world in your realm but branching
out and taking care of of issues that
are not necessarily your problem but
things that you must take care of and
the final thing i believe is conquest so
having a goal having a name wanting to
put a dent in the universe
and then the through line between all of
these three concepts is emotional
control so for me
the hallmark of masculinity is emotional
control it doesn't matter how you feel
when you get up in the morning there's a
job to be done and you have to do it
right uh you know young men storming the
beaches of normandy you know didn't cry
in the corner they they went out there
and they they won the war they defeated
the nazis
but conversely as well if you were to
look at a woman who had high emotional
control who had goals that she was going
to go and get after who was courageous
and brave and chasing those things down
that would be
it would certainly be an outlier it
would be the sort of woman that you
would expect would be
uh rising up through a law firm or
starting her own business you know
that's if you if you have boss [ __ ]
like that's what would go next to it
yes yes it's it's it that's also
fascinating as well that we typically
apply these characteristics to males
more than we do females and i i think
it's it has to do a lot with how we're
socialized and the sort of media that we
consume
in that we we attribute these characters
to strong men as opposed to strong women
which as you pointed out it you know
women can and do have these these
qualities but they're typically the very
end the very upper echelon of their
fields they dominate their dominance
hierarchies as jordan peterson would
probably put it well the reason being
that disagreeableness you know to go
down the jordan peterson
disagreeableness and a bunch of other
psychological traits will tend people in
that are males toward having this type
of an approach to life
yes yes so disagreeableness is a
fascinating characteristic so the big
five personality traits if
one wanted to be a success in a specific
field or reach the top of their
dominance hierarchy they would have to
be low in agreeableness and high in
disagreeableness because it's a matter
of getting getting one's way and not
being a pushover being a monster in
jordan peterson's uh phraseology and a
lot of that involves i think peterson he
refers to carl jung so he young talks
about integrating one shadow so taking
the the negative or dangerous part of
oneself and using it to one's own ends
and disagreeability is i think a large
part of that yeah and i suppose that a
lack of disagreeability is precisely
what you're seeing with simps
yes yes so to that point of description
of
discrepability when we talk about
economics
one study demonstrated that if someone
was
a man in particular was one standard
deviation below uh the level of
agreeableness they would
have um they would earn 18 percent more
than a man who was one standard
deviation above the baseline
agreeableness which means that
discriminable people make more money
than agreeable people
and also potentially get laid more or
are more attractive to the opposite sex
however
i would say and we can get into this the
converse would be
untrue
for women
that if you have a woman who is
increasingly disagreeable that she is
probably going to be less attractive as
a mate
yes yes because disagreeableness i think
is more of a masculine characteristic at
least based on the psychological the um
psychological evidence the cognitive
psychology would indicate that to be the
case and i think on average on average
is the term we're probably going to be
using everything's on average everything
is on average good god dude
but on average men are more disagreeable
and they're typically looking for a
woman that is feminine and if if a woman
i would say possesses a quality of
disagreeableness it probably makes her
more masculine than it does feminine and
i think that's what puts a lot of men
off to disagreeable boss [ __ ] as you
put it yeah what's a dark gentleman
ah so dark gentleman is a term i've
coined uh to reflect a man who has both
dark triad characteristics in some
capacity but is also benevolent so he's
not your you know psycho chad you know
uh narcissist
that wants to sleep with women but he
also incorporates the three ps that is
parental investment protection and
provision so it's this it's just what i
like to call a unity of contradiction so
combining
two things which are in logical contrast
but molding them together such that they
work in harmony
that's really interesting
so that's because there is a there is a
particular
degree of attraction that women have
toward dark triad traits why is that yes
yes those men are sexy right it's it's
the it's the um these characteristics
make people make these sorts of people
seem as though they're important right
there's that danger
that is often attributed to a man that
is that is uh psychopathic or
machiavellian and with narcissism it
makes perfect sense right a guy that
dresses well has
you know smiles uh
is very attractive in other words so he
he fulfills that chad component but a
man who is fully on the dark triad
spectrum doesn't necessarily fulfill the
dad perspective which women are also
looking for on a long-term perspective
so if you're actually combining the
short term which is the dark triad
aspect of it and the long term
perspective which is the the dad you
know
triple p perspective
you're getting the perfect guy in a
sense you're getting that unicorn
because you need an element or most men
with elements of dark triad traits are
more successful in short-term mating
opportunities but make bad term long bad
long-term mate prospects so getting
yourself uh
through the door so to speak um
with the dark triad traits and then
continuing and adding longevity to the
relationship with your three ps so the
chad and dad
yes precisely that so i was actually
having a conversation with jordan
peterson about this where he was saying
that
women want a man that is disagreeable
but also agreeable at the same time
because disagreeability is actually a
law of diminishing returns where you
know if a man is disagreeable in in uh
his workplace right he's probably gonna
get an advance as we discuss in terms of
economics they typically make more money
but in a domestic setting a high level
of disagreeability doesn't work very
well so if your wife tells you hey baby
go take take out the trash and you say
no i don't want to do so i'm
disagreeable it's probably not going to
be conducive to a long and happy
marriage
but it's as with everything man you need
a balance
yes you don't want to be out
on the
top 10th percentile or bottom 10th
percentile of anything ever really
i said i was sad i was um i tried to
justify uh
the number one
competitive advantage in the modern
world is to be 10 autistic over a
thanksgiving dinner
you just want you just want it's like
you know that the salt bay guy you just
want that much you want that much autism
and it's yeah yeah yeah precisely just a
smattering you know i think there's i
think there's probably some truth to
that because you want to have that sort
of gung-ho kind of [ __ ] you mentality
where you kind of just go off and do
your own thing yup and kind of just
throw caution to the wind but you kind
of have to dial it back
in since you can't go you can't i'm
going to use a
it's going to get me canceled if i use
it but it's sort of a traffic tropic
thunder thunder term i think the phrase
is go full [ __ ] as it were yep
that's fine i've used i've used i used
that i used that last week on the
podcast i don't know i'm talking about
jordan peace i'm not famous not to get
cancelled so okay uh so you've got a
quote here from the article we're
talking about a man who is too
ingratiating is ultimately a man who is
too desperate his inability to tell a
woman no is a direct reflection of his
over eagerness to please contrary to
popular belief telling a woman no in
specific circumstances is an attractive
quality as it signals that a man is not
a pilot doormat
yes yes you'd be surprised how
sexy saying no is to a woman because
you're sort of putting your foot down
you're taking a stand you're saying i'm
the man in the situation
and
a lot of women not all of them but you
know again we use the term on average
you're looking for leadership within a
relationship
and sometimes that requires saying no
and and taking the bull by the horns and
really taking the steering wheel and
also making decisions right
oh yeah oh yeah i mean look
if if you're in a relationship and
you're constantly stressed and you're
worried about life
would it not be better if you had
someone who was able to make decisions
in a cogent manner is able to lead lead
you along it's not to say that women are
incapable of making decisions or a man
is more capable of making decisions but
it's just it's just that less more or
less or less stressful when you have
someone there that is clear of thought
and clear of mind and is able to make
decisions yeah i mean what would you say
to the people that say why why is that
the man's job why can't that be the
woman's job
well it can be either one of their jobs
right it sort of depends on the
relationship i'm not i i guess the point
i'm trying to get across here is that
it's not
different relationships work differently
for different people and so abiding by
the stereotypical notion that men should
always be the leader in a family i don't
think it's true if it doesn't work for
you and your partner so it may work it
may be the case that it works for most
people but some couples might find it
easier if the woman makes all the
decisions financially socially whatever
it is
you do need a polarity though having two
agreeable people or two disagreeable
people is a recipe for a [ __ ] always
you always need a a polarity between the
two it's a good point you've raised here
is that uh one one um
sort of guy that was writing on this
idea i forget what who he is and what
the book was but he said that for a good
relationship to work specifically when
it comes to to sex is that you need a
ravisher and a person that's ravished
ravished
and the same thing applies here in in uh
in in a relationship right you need uh
you need that that um
polarity right that unity of
contradictions i'm not sure that i would
agree with regards to the sex thing
because what you see in gay
circles is that the sexual protagonist
and the sexual gatekeeper has had the
gatekeeper removed and the gate
the gate's wide open um and they seem to
have a lot of sex my buddies that are
gay when they go to cruising grounds and
and uh festivals and stuff like that
they they come back and you know they've
got an abacus to try and keep track of
how many people they've had sex with
sure but there's a sub dom dynamic isn't
there typically yes during the during
the sexual dynamic um yeah but certainly
i mean the most interesting thing is
for me especially with courting and
mating and and getting from uh date to
sex is the fact that women are almost
always the sexual gatekeepers that men
are almost always the sexual
protagonists and um you may have seen
rob tweeted something the other day
talking about the percentage of women in
the percentage of men that prefer to be
asked out on a date versus those that
prefer to do the asking
and there is an asymmetry there there's
like a whatever a six to ten percent
variance between the number of men that
prefer to be asked out and the number of
women that are prepared to do the asking
yes yeah yes no i i completely agree
with that i mean it's it's i'm happy
that rob is has posted something about
that because i think in my personal you
know uh uh experience that has always
been the case that i'm the one that
always has to make the first move in
initiating a date or getting a number
whatever it is right because you know
you know she's nice and she's she's out
there in the corner and talking to her
friends but i'm gonna have to cross the
room and ask her for her number
but that's reflective of the dynamic
that she holds
the keys
to the resource that mostly people are
trying to get which is sexual access but
the the dynamic gets reversed right that
women hold the keys to sex but men hold
the keys to relationships
relationships correct correct i
completely agree with that point and it
it harkens back to this notion or this
idea that i've had is
whether or not men are more powerful
than women
based on the fact that women hold the or
the gatekeepers to the sexual
marketplace as it were that men are
after sex right and there's this
economist that has this idea that
everything men have done
in terms of building is premised on
receiving sex from females so you know
you jump out of a plane uh you know you
build a company you do it because you
want to get laid maybe it's true maybe
it's not but i think there's some merit
to that because we're all we're all
after reproduction right spreading our
seed reproducing
you know passing on our gene to the next
generation and if that's the case well
women are in essence powerful because
they they are as you say the gatekeepers
to the sexual marketplace
and they determine who who gets to pass
on their genes and who doesn't
there's an episode of futurama where uh
sex robots are distributed to everyone
on the planet and nothing happens
anymore everyone just stops working
so yes that's a great job yeah that's
that's like this that's the situation
you're talking about there's another
quote that you put in here saying
according to pew research 51 of men
between the ages of 18 and 29 are single
compared to 32 percent of women in the
same age group
ah
how the [ __ ] does that work because this
the gender split of men and women is
around about 50 50.
well it probably works because there's a
there's probably uh
a small percentage of men or an outside
proportion of men not probably a small
percentage of men that are dating a lot
of these women and when
probably perceive that they're in a
relationship with these men when in
actuality he's probably dating a variety
of different women and you know tied to
that concept of that 51 of men is the
notion that the reason why they're
single is primarily because they're too
afraid to ask a woman out and it goes
back to that concept we're talking about
rejection so
guys using only fans it sort of takes
away the sting of rejection
yes what was that the ineffectiveness of
simping lies in its pedestrialization of
women in the absence of genuine intimacy
while the gentleman holds doors and pays
for dinner and engages in the women with
women on an emotional level the simp
inundates a woman with extravagant gifts
and superficial praise the simp engages
in romantic bribery attempting to buy a
woman's love and that's just
not gonna work no it doesn't because i
look i i'm of the belief that women are
masters at spotting [ __ ] they can
see it a mile away especially when it
comes to romantic conquest and if a man
is not genuine in his intentions and his
his courtship of her she's gonna spot
that very very quickly
how would a simp not be genuine
well if it's always about giving undue
praise and gifts well there's there's
something wrong there right if there
isn't any
pure emotional interaction if there is
isn't any need to engage her beyond
simply giving her praise and attention
well he's not really going to get
through the front door is he uh so
there's a there's a
underwritten expected reciprocation
which isn't being adhered to
yes and there's sort of this cat mouse
game that you could probably play with
the girl that you're trying to court
right i think that push and push and
pull uh process is what it's referred to
and if if all you're doing is giving
attention to a female your attention is
worthless
it's like getting getting too much of
something makes it makes it essentially
worthless so you know i don't know what
your favorite food is but let's say you
love pizza if you had pizza every single
day it no longer becomes your favorite
food because you're eating it on a daily
basis and it loses its luster over time
and the same thing applies with the
tension in this case here where the
value of a man's attention is lost if
it's constant
the number of men aged 18 to 30 who
report having no sex in the past year
has tripled between 2008 and 2018 so
this is pre-pandemic and i imagine it
must have gotten an awful lot worse
through the pandemic as well why do you
think this is happening
it was probably higher than 31 of
whatever it was when it was reported
because that's not something that that a
lot of men would actually report to
people it's sort of it's stigmatized
right the male the male virgin is
something which is stigmatized within
society but i think the reason why this
is is
again it's a complex question which
probably has a multivariate answer yeah
so
it could be the case that it's men being
pushed out of the sexual marketplace
because women are typically looking for
a guy
at uh at the you know the 10 the 90th
percentile right the the power few as it
were at the end of the par law
distribution
that could be a potential reason so
they're not finding
women that are necessarily interested in
them because they are let's say average
right socioeconomically speaking it
could be the case that they've actually
dropped out of the sexual marketplace so
excessive use of pornography playing
video games not putting themselves in a
situation in which they can court women
and actually
engage with them
that is probably another reason why
for me i think that's that's a big two
but go on go on that's interesting so
i think
you know black pill intel culture red
pill kevin samuels fans everyone wants
to blame the lack of sex or the vast
majority of people want to blame the
lack of sex on a women's standards being
too high or at least for the
people who aren't familiar with this
corner of the internet that's a a big
explanation but the fact that some men
have chosen to retreat from dating
because there's simply other more fun
things to do you know it's not just
about the
black pills that can't and the red pills
that won't it's the mgtows that choose
not to
yes men that go their own way absolutely
correct and like a lot of this comes
down to effort if if you actually want
to have a girlfriend and actually have a
meaningful relationship with a girl
you're gonna have to try you're gonna
have to put your yourself out there and
you're gonna have to suffer rejection
rejection i think is a is a large part
about um
it really is a masculine feature so
dealing with rejection of course females
as well can deal with rejection but
dealing with rejection and handling it
is how you you build a backbone right
it's how you develop a thick skin and
the more times you suffer rejection in
you know when it comes to dating and
courtship
the better you are at it
why do you think
we are so terrified of rejection as men
pain
suffering no one likes to feel as though
they're inadequate and
jordan peterson actually again go back
to going back to him he has this
fantastic line about uh when a man
suffers rejection when he's when a woman
says no to him
she's essentially saying that she
doesn't want to reproduce with you and
uh carry on your genetic line it's a
it's a fundamental shot to the ego and
nobody wants that
but you know
again if you do want to actually achieve
that right to spread your um your genes
as it were you're gonna have to take
hits
do you think that women feel the same
pain of rejection just that they ask
less frequently than men and that they
will passively get they are uh how would
you say
they're getting passive traffic
uh and men are having to create active
adverts uh to use the online marketing
binocular
yes good good uh good uh terms there
good phraseology how many girls have
actively asked you out
it's in dude over 15 years of being out
and about on nights out i can remember
most of them i'm talking single digits
yes as can i it's like maybe two
it's it's not that much right and so
women aren't taking the you know the the
the active effort to engage with a man
and ask him for his number and so
therefore they don't suffer as much
rejection but when they do suffer the
rejection i can imagine that it's pretty
damn painful because it's not in your
nature let's say to actually put
yourself out there and initiate the
conversation or initiate the engagement
so you've already overcome something
you've already decided to make an
increased effort on top of what you
think should be done this is outside my
normal operating process
schedule
and it still hasn't worked well if
there's i want to hear
the girls that are listening
put a comment on youtube or whatever and
and tell us what you think because if
let us know what the pain of rejection
is like
and whether or not whether or not you
think it's as bad as your male
counterparts
yes fascinating i i would love to see
the uh the comment yeah well we need you
to do a date to dive on it um yeah it's
it's a weird one man i
do not think
is there something deeper than that is
the what would it be evolutionarily why
would it be the case that
a woman saying no is so painful is it
that
there is a limited number of women and
that this is a reminder of your place in
the status hierarchy within the tribe of
the 100 people that you know and of
those hundred people maybe
four of them are available women that
are of the right age for you
yes it's a
it's probably a mark of inadequacy
so being told no that one cannot
reproduce is
is very painful
and evolutionary speaking uh
most of we have more female ancestors
than we do male ancestors which
indicates that a
small percentage of men in antiquity in
ancient times actually reproduced
and so this is a good thing and a bad
thing in a way it's bad obviously
because a lot of men are dying without
reproducing but it's probably a good
thing in a sense because
women are
selecting the best possible mates and so
it it sort of it it improves our genetic
line when all the the top stock males
are selected virgins verging
terrifyingly close to people posting
eugenics in the comments below here
vincent which is dude i agree with you i
agree with you the fact that selection
pressures from women choosing things
which are uh outward displays of fitness
charisma all of the reasons why is it
that you think that the things that you
find attractive you find attractive
why for
everything my favorite example of this
right um
the preferred body size of women over
time is fluctuated you've gone from
bigger women you know marilyn monroe
wasn't a thin
famous actress uh right up to the thigh
gap desire of sort of the early 2000s to
now kind of the more like fit chick
insta bum bbl [ __ ] that you've got now
however yes throughout all of time the
preferred waist to hip ratio of women
has remained the same and it's always
been around 0.82
why because women that have a higher
waist to hip ratio on average are more
fertile the same thing goes for large
eyes flushed lips uh
rosy cheeks because those are signs of
youth youth also equals fertility with
men the v taper is precisely the same
preferred body size for men over time
has changed but an increase in width an
increase in jaw size an increase in brow
ridge are all signals of high
testosterone testosterone equals more
status more resources more go-getter
probably more disagreeable i would
imagine that men who have higher levels
of testosterone are more disagreeable as
well so like all of the things that we
happen to like even symmetrical faces
it's genetically more difficult to grow
a symmetrical face than an unsymmetrical
face and then you have the sexy sun
hypothesis if i'm attracted to this man
my children will be attractive therefore
our genetic lineage will continue more
easily um
all of these things the reason that
you're attracted to the things that
you're attracted to is mostly because
they are signals of fitness
and
realizing that realizing that
i had a robert ploman on the show
behavioral uh geneticist and
people get real uncomfortable talking
about behavioral genetics because it it
reminds them of eugenics in a way that
it absolutely shouldn't um and the only
person that you should complain about if
you are throwing the eugenics term
around a behavioral geneticist is why
aren't you dating that homeless four
foot four
jobless man on the street that doesn't
wash like why or the guy why aren't you
dating that girl that you can't bear to
look at and is super annoying and super
disagreeable why
that's that's eugenics as well
yes yes well
that was a fantastic summary of the
literature that was great chris i really
like that
but basically what this comes down to is
ancient ideas in modern skulls so a lot
of what we do
at the level of of course there are
idiosyncrasies between people we like
what we like for a variety of reasons
and maybe social so there's that notion
that we marry people like our parents
but even still that is a combination of
of um
biological determinism and
sort of social rearing but at the same
time
the evolutionary
lens here is incredibly important that a
lot of what we find attractive so you
pointed out youth infertility when it
comes to men and their maid preferences
is something which is borne out in the
in in evolution right this is these are
things which we look for
um men
in looking for women and on
for females the same sort of thing
applies with as you mentioned the v
taper with men having certain physical
characteristics which made them more of
a protector and more of a provider women
are typically going to in antiquity as
well as in as today
put their their interest or their their
lot behind a man who's capable of taking
care of them
and that was especially the case in in
evolutionary in an evolutionary area
asian times but it's also carried off uh
over today
what are some of the unique challenges
that we've got with modern mate
selection
well the primary problem and
i do think that it is
verging into a very very very serious
issue
is the imbalance in the sexual
marketplace where there is a
presumably a small percentage of men who
are
receiving the most attention from women
that women want men in the upper echelon
socio-economically speaking right they
want a man that earns
top 10 percent in terms of income that
has a square jaw line that has a
six-pack you know is is in the top ten
in terms of height as well and
these characteristics when put together
uh equate for a very small percentage of
men and if the majority of women are
vying for these men and ignoring the
rest of them that creates not only a
large number of lonely women but it
creates a lot of sexually frustrated men
and those two things are not are not
necessarily or not even very good if
we're looking at
a prosperous society why is that a
modern phenomenon surely these impulses
have been with us throughout time
so the impulse is yes the one impulse
being hypergamy so woman dating upwards
is something which has been ingrained
and constant throughout
human existence but i think the three
things which have changed at least in
the last 50 years are
one female achievement so women are
typically earning more than men in a
certain age bracket and they're going to
college at a higher rate so just to give
you an example of the statistics so in
the 1960s there were 1.6 men to every
female at a four-year u.s college
by 2003 there are 1.35 women for every
man in a four-year us college and women
are going to college and earning degrees
at a higher rate than men and this also
applies to postgraduate degrees where
something like 12 percent of women have
a postgraduate degree relative to
percent of men and
when it comes to the economics as well
these the press association compiled a
lot of data looking at uh economics so
earnings and what they found was that
women between the ages of 20 and 29 made
on average one thousand one hundred and
eleven pounds
more than a man in that same age
demographic so that's one point the one
factor being
improved uh female attainment the second
factor is that there's a greater
variability among males and this is with
regard to economic earnings and such
right all the characteristics that you
would look for in a viable partner that
there is a wider distribution of men
economically so making more money
maintaining more sexual partners and so
this variability is of course going to
play to that that top 10 percent of men
and the third thing is i think this is
an important one because it's it's
probably with regard or with relation to
technology so an expansion or
globalization of a section of the sexual
marketplace and the collapse of local of
local status hierarchies where things
like instagram things like tinder are
making it such that there's an
international pool of partners with
which you can select from that you
couldn't have before so 50 years ago you
know you'd probably meet someone
a romantic
a romantic prospect in a in a bar local
bar or at a rec center or whatever it is
certainly my parents met locally right
they were maybe from different villages
or something but you know they it was it
was a local phenomenon but today
everything is international everything
is globalized and that all these
characteristics together along with
hypergamy has resulted in this massive
imbalance
how is it if there's women out educating
and out earning men between the ages of
20 and 29
how is it that there's still a commonly
held assumption in the culture about men
out earning out earning women about
women being held back
do you want the the uh sort of dude bro
answer
both give me all of them both well the
dude bro answer is that people are dumb
and uninformed and they typically go
along with memes and messages that's a
joke by the way i don't think people are
dumb i think it's a matter of of just
the amount of information that's being
presented and how it's being presented
because if if members of the media are
just presenting that narrative over and
over again it's going to stick right
it's we're just playing off heuristics
here
uh i think that's the main thing that's
the reason why this narrative sticks
this notion of the gender pay gap is
sticking around despite the copious
amounts of research done about it the
fact that if you actually disaggregate
the the um
the data if you looked at hours worked
if you looked at industry if you looked
at job type occupation these sorts of
things you would see that there's a
reason why it is that men on average
make more than women not to mention the
fact that women between the ages of of
20 and 29 make more make more money than
men within that age demographic
what happens at age you know 29 is after
that it's probably motherhood so it's
not even a question of men and women
making more or less than the other it's
a question of everyone else making more
than mothers
the interesting thing to me i've been
thinking about this for so long is
the presumption
amongst common culture and people that
put forward
this
the idea about the gender wage gap is
that the inherently masculine frame
is the
attainable admirable preferable one that
everybody should be playing on it's like
the
values that we've typically associated
with men or with masculinity or with
men's uh trajectory through life
is the one
those are the rules of the game that
everybody should be playing by and now
we need to kind of manipulate it so that
everyone gets to play that game does
that make sense
uh yeah sort of i think so think about
the fact think about the fact that um
there are a lot of women out there who
might want to
wipe the floor with men and get their
postgraduate degree and earn you know a
grand in a bit more per year throughout
all of their 20s but can't wait to
become mothers and don't actually mind
about the fact that they get to become
mothers and yet the woman that decides
to do that is seen through this
particular lens as lesser because she's
decided to play the game that isn't the
typical masculinity approach well why
haven't you only taken
your three months maternity leave
because you know in i think it's in
australia you kind of have like this big
block of time and you can repurpose it
between the man and the woman across
both jobs i don't really know how that
works because the two companies are
gonna be different but uh anyway
uh yeah why is it that you're not going
straight back to work that to me i must
imagine for women that really can't wait
to be mothers must provide a level of
ambient anxiety and maybe even guilt
around the fact that they have decided
to either be a mother or go back to work
when they should feel like they're doing
the opposite
that probably has to do quite a bit with
societal pressure so you know women
needing to work or not even societal
pressure but just an economic economic
pressure yes so the fact that both
adults in the household need to work in
order to provide for for everyone else
is a is a clear factor here but to your
point
that that is also an interesting thing
where it is assumed that a woman should
go off and and get a job and do and do
all those sorts of things but what if
she doesn't want to right all this comes
down to personal choice if you want to
work and achieve a phd and be a captive
of industry as a woman you're free to do
so
do it but if you decide that at the age
of 21 or even at the age of 18 before
you even go to a uh college
that you want to be a mother you can do
that also i don't see the problem with
it the issue is that people have to
understand that there are consequences
and and uh and benefits to doing certain
things and we all have to live with it
you can't simply do something and then
complain about the action or the the
results of the action
rolling the clock forward then
you can only have long term
realistically you can only have at one
time one man to one woman unless you're
in some crazy polygamy
retreat somewhere um with that in mind
you would expect women to adjust their
dating strategies
in order to be able to find themselves a
mate but based on the stats it doesn't
really seem like that's bearing out
no no that's correct and i think this
probably comes down to hypergamy as well
is that woman
won't settle
well the average woman probably won't
settle she'll probably go after the type
of man that she wants and if she doesn't
get him she's more than happy to be
single
it's more than happy to to work on her
career and do what she needs to do
which is again perfectly fine you do
what you you want to do you do what you
need to do
but it obviously becomes an issue when
there is a lot of men out there without
a partner
without a you know a person that um you
know is there for them and you know
societies where
young men are
without partners
are ones that typically
become to stabilize and crumble within a
short period of time a short span of
time
so i think in antiquity as well uh
that
i'm trying to remember the uh this is an
ancient society that had this particular
issue but but certainly it's the case
that when young men uprising when they
don't necessarily have a productive
means of actually you know conforming
cartooning themselves they will
typically tear society apart
i mean everybody knows
the dynamics that you're talking about
everybody knows the guy friend who is a
complete savage and doesn't really care
about who he goes home with after he's
had a couple of drinks right we all have
that we all have that buddy at
university
not many of us had that girl buddy at
university or far less
so right um
yeah it
i don't know it strikes me as
as a
particularly sort of unfortunate
combination of circumstances another one
being that if you have um
more lacks rules around casual sex
before marriage and uh birth control
which means that you can have sex
without fear of having children that
means that women can have sex with high
value men
who are outside of their typical dating
pool and perhaps higher value than they
would usually have access to which then
skews their
goals moving forward about who they want
to be in a long-term relationship with
what they don't understand is that that
man was prepared to give them sex but
not prepared to give them a relationship
relationship yep
yes yes that's an incredibly important
point here uh
it's
it's a matter of knowing what's
available and what you can actually
attain being realistic about your
romantic prospects so that high value
man that is a top 10 percent earner that
drives a bugatti was probably never
going to entertain a romantic
relationship with you so
why try to court him
at the outset right what was the benefit
there maybe it was it was a fun night
and maybe you do enjoy
engaging with them but you are right
when you say that it probably distorts
their perception of what then is
available because if if you do have this
experience with this guy and it was a
fantastic experience and your head over
heels for him
you want to replicate that experience in
in in the next-door relationships you
have but if that guy that you're dating
doesn't quite reach that standard you're
never going to be happy well which girl
wants to admit to herself that this guy
with the nice car and the good abs only
wants me to [ __ ] me no one wants no no
girl's going to be able to
do that you know you not only would you
probably not know but even if you did
know you wouldn't be able to justify it
to yourself in any case um
you know it's the same as the guy the
same as the guy that sleeps with the
really really ugly girl he'll probably
justify it to himself as well actually
she's not that bad and it's just that
the only thing no dude it's because
you've had eight pints and you're in a
city that you've never been in before
and you're lonely that's why yes
i don't know man i think um i think it'd
be very difficult for a girl to kind of
concede that point
you know
one of the main reasons would be men
give off signals of long-term mating
strategies very few men you know no
matter how alpha you are are going to
say um hope that you've got your uber
booked for 3 30 a.m tonight um type
thing as you're on the as you're on the
way back oh hi mate can you just wait
outside in the cab while while we get
this done and then you can take her home
most men aren't honest and open about
their short-term mating intentions which
let's lead with leading women on
yes
i think that that is true but at the
same time
does
does being open make a man more or less
attractive with regard to his intention
so if if you met a girl right away and
you took her out on a first date or even
maybe even a second date and you said to
her uh my intention is to marry you does
that make you more or less attractive if
you are that transparent i mean what do
you think maybe
i would say that's probably coming on
too strong
that's crummy on too strong right so
that sort of transparency may not
necessarily work in that particular
situation
well the most bizarre thing is that
the men who have
no intention of being in a long-term
relationship with you usually give off
signals that they do
and the men who do want to be in a
long-term relationship with you try to
give off signals that they're not
yes but but that's the thing though is
that it's it's a strange it's a strange
way that um
i suppose the female mind perceives
attractive males and it probably comes
back to the point about attention is
that you want that which you cannot have
you know and if you can't have the the
man that is uh you know the upper
echelon of man the high value man you'll
want him even more
roll the clock forward for me then like
there's gonna be a lot of single women
in future what's gonna happen there
because um do you think that women can
uh reset their hypergamous nature
no no that's that's an evolutionary
fixture that's gonna stick around for
quite a while uh things are probably
gonna get far worse than they are better
before everything is said and done
what's that mean but um well
it means i think we're probably going to
see a lot more
violence with with relation to incels i
think that's probably going to go up as
a result of the influx of lonely single
men
and
of course you're going to see quite a
bit more depression among single single
women in fact i think there's a
statistic out there that indicates that
women
caucasian females between the ages of 40
and 45 have the highest rates of
antidepressant use
and that is probably going to increase
as as time goes on but probably spread
out to other age demographics 40 and 45
i believe so so do you think that that's
women who have perhaps
uh not dated or dated unsuccessfully and
made it to the wall uh without a partner
and are now
accepting their sort of
childless future yes i i think so but
there is there is some saving grace so
if i were to added a
contradictory statistic here it's that
the only
uh demographic among females where
there's been an increase in in
infertility and in children being born
is that same demographic is women
between the ages of 40 and 40 45. i want
to say i want to say that more women had
in 2019 had children over the age of 40
than under the age of 20. correct
correct that's exactly correct i think
um so peer research actually put out a
study not too long ago and it 20
uh 2016 was 80 of women
between the age of 14 45 that had a a
child and that actually increased by six
percent as of 2019.
that's correct it's slowly it's yeah
it's slowly ticking upwards
and that you know to be honest the
average age of women having children
increasing is probably due to the fact
that we're having uh
less uh children out of well not quite
children out of wedlock but children um
born to teenage parents let's say
teenage women is that happening
yes yes so it's not the case that
children are not being born out of
wedlock that is actually going up and
it's it's quite it's quite a substantial
amount but
sort of
safe sex practices
that sort of thing has been instrumental
in reducing the rate of teenage
pregnancy
i read in the moral animal by robert
wright about how monogamy is a sexual
redistribution strategy
oh yeah yeah so this this really
fascinated me the fact that if you have
one man with many women you allow one
particular man to capture most of the
market whereas if you have one man with
one woman you actually end up um
allowing man number two to get woman
number two whereas previously he would
have been looking at woman number eleven
because
women one to ten would have been with
man number one and
that um that kind of explains i think
some of the resentment that you see in
the black pill culture and in the
in-cell culture around these chads these
high-value men that are able to sleep
with many women because they see them as
tying up
available women's reproduction potential
during fertile years when they could
have been dating other people and also
uh how would you say kind of bunching up
the line
moving the queue tighter and tighter
together
in a way which has trickle-down effect
that has potentially competed them out
of the dating market
absolutely so these these uh black ball
guys will as the meme goes they hate
chad and stacy and
it's it's funny you mentioned that
because i you are correct so and um the
researcher i forget the name that you
mentioned robert wright is the book
robert wright yes entirely correct i
think in that
monogamy in in the um the grand scheme
of things is probably a a newer concept
a newer thing that's come about it was
never the case in antiquity that we
engaged in monogamy it was typically
polygamous right we had harems and such
and
i do think that there is an argument to
be made about returning to that
specifically when we talk about
imbalances in the sexual marketplace
with a small percentage of men hogging a
large percentage of women so if we look
at tinder data for example
it's
you know
most of the men on tinder of the
profiles they come across females
they'll swipe right on from 60 of them
when it comes to females they'll only
swipe right on 4.5 percent of them so
that is a massive imbalance just on
twitter usage and that that is even
compounded by the fact that 78 of
individuals that use tinder are male and
so 22 percent of people that use tinder
are female which means of the
demographic of the smallest demographic
in terms of gender the vast majority of
those these women are being selected
by the vast majority of men and the
opposite is not true for females
dude i've just realized the implication
of what you're saying and i've never
thought of this before i think about
this [ __ ] a lot right i've read
everything that you've read i've read a
lot of stuff around red pill and black
pill
and i've only just realized that one of
the potential solutions to this is to go
back to a polygamous uh culture
because if women can't get rid of their
hypergamous nature
if we can't rise uh raise men's uh level
of competition up in order to be able to
match the women
one of the solutions to make fewer
people overall be single is to have many
women with one man at the top and then
just leave the men at the bottom to be
cast away that's [ __ ] terrifying
that's terrifying and it's it's not what
we want to do
that is a recipe for disaster that is a
recipe for social upheaval and just
societal disintegration if men are
simply cast aside because they're
inadequate
[ __ ] but that's the case at the moment
that's the case at the moment with it
being non-polygamous
non-polygamous correct so imagine a
society like china where there is a
massive gender imbalance based off of
the the one child policy that they
initiated you know centuries back and
now looking at the the modern sexual
dynamics
what do you think is going to come of
that society in 50 to 100 years if if
all this if our hypotheses here are
correct and this plays its course do you
think are you talking about if you have
one man with many women
yes so the so in essence so as we just
pointed out it's it's that uh polygamous
that's uh polygamy set up where it's one
men with with many women and the rest of
these men who are incapable of attaining
a sexual partner are being left in the
dust but the only thing that they have
to bind together over is their mutual
hatred of chad and stacy of chad and
stacy
yes [ __ ] man that's so i never thought
of the fact
that a potential solution and i'm gonna
guess there'll be a utilitarian
rationalist out there who would say that
this is actually an optimal outcome as
long as you can control this underclass
of sexless men um that you actually end
up reducing the number of people overall
that are single by doing this
but you very very much create
a
a bifurcated society you have the haves
and the have-nots and the matthew
principle comes out with this as well so
i mean as an example i think
robert wright explains i can't remember
it was in 1994 he wrote this book man
it's so pressing it's amazing and um but
at the time maybe the richest man was
like warren buffett or something it's
like a really unsexy example and he
talks about the fact that uh you could
have the richest man in the world that's
worth however many billion and he could
fund the lives
using money as a proxy for resources
which is one of the fundamental things
that women want from a man uh
he would be able to fund
like
10 000 women's lives the same as as one
millionaire
and
when you think about that you go well
okay obviously women want more than just
monetary access they actually want
emotional control emotional
connection they want to be able to feel
like they're part of a working capacity
family and so on and so forth uh
but when you think about it like that
and if the choice is between being
completely single as a woman as you get
into your 30s
or being one of many with a man who you
know can look after you because he's one
of these
super earners with all of the resources
and all of the status uh
i don't know i don't know how tempting
that ends up sounding
incredibly tempting i would i would
assume because it's it's the prospect of
being funded
pretty much winning the lottery ticket
when it comes to these these warren
buffet types and having to raise
children with a man that you're not
necessarily attracted with or attracted
to or even happy with that doesn't
necessarily provide the sort of life
that you want well the third option is
obviously second is to continue
uh leading a
solo range of life and yes i think that
the from a utilitarian perspective it
would like why why isn't everyone in a
relationship with elon musk like i
should be in a relationship with elon
musk based on utilitarian approach well
it's because he's building he's busy
building rockets i think that's what the
issue is he's not he's not he doesn't
have the time for that sort of thing but
a terrible joke aside yes
your point is well taken yes um
because it's you know what it is i think
it's just it's a matter of
unfamiliarity so this sort of dynamic
that we're describing is not something
that people subscribe to normally right
something which is entirely foreign to
us given the fact that a new the nuclear
family and monogamy is
given the fact that these two things are
still ingrained within within the way we
do relationships today so while it may
not be palatable today it might be
palatable in 10 20 years time 50
potentially that was the
aftershock of the renaissance right the
as roller tomassie founder of the red
pill calls it the one itis the belief
that there is one true love and this was
very much pushed through the renaissance
and then if you think about popular
recent culture you've got disney movies
like aladdin that really really just
fundamentally create this there is
someone out there that is perfectly
built for you and you will spend the
rest of your life together
yes so i i have a bone to pick with
disney i have an axe to grind with them
because i think the disney vacation of
romantic relationships is incredibly
dangerous
so uh so are are you uh your parents
still together yes
yes so
our grandparents on our parents are
they typically have lower rates of
divorce because the
basis the relationship was not
necessarily based on their happiness per
se it was more so
getting things done and ensuring that
these children were raised in a correct
manner right and that often meant
putting up with the opposite sex putting
up with your partner despite the fact
that they're behaving like a [ __ ] on
that specific day today things i think
are different because again it's that
disney vacation of romantic
relationships where if it's not perfect
if it's not a fairy tale i don't want it
and so it is subject to divorce and it
again goes back to that concept of
suffering and hardship and rejection you
know how good was the relationship to
begin with if once you hit a rough patch
you immediately give up
i think that you see this as well
with the increasing masculinization or
the masculine frame that women are being
encouraged to take to
you know uh don't settle for less clap
back be a boss [ __ ] i know that these
are all kind of funny twitter memes but
they permeate the you know
phenomenologically they're in the back
of someone's mind they're in the back of
a girl's mind the fact that he doesn't
deserve you babe all of that sort of
stuff
is
averse to
working through challenges with a man
who is on a par with your sexual
marketplace value
and the same thing goes for the guys
it's like plenty more fish in the sea
get over your last girlfriend by getting
under the next one you know the there
are many memes on both sides of the
fence here now they're being played in
different ways the men are being
reminded to reinforce their masculine
traits and the women are being reminded
that a protectionist strategy is to
adopt masculine traits
but again what we're seeing i i need to
i might i need to ring rob for like
three hours and talk it through but
there is a masculine frame a masculine
preference which is being
it's like when you varnish a table and
it's just it's just like a smattering
across everything or it's like the
direction that the wind is pushing
whether that be with how you're supposed
to spend your relationships how you're
supposed to um think about education how
you're supposed to think about your
career
all of these things they really do seem
to be pushing in that direction but
with the women's side of things um yeah
they're being encouraged to not accept a
not a subpar mate but a uh difficult
situation
yeah difficult situation with a
uh equitable mate
yes yes
it's a problem and obviously you're
making the point here about ideas and
memes and it's it's not just a meme it's
it's a mode of thinking that is being
inculcated by young women and also young
men to an extent and it's incredibly
problematic that this this notion that
one must not necessarily settle it's
fine right i don't think you should ever
settle per se but it's it's more so that
you should be very realistic about what
it is that's attainable and what it is
that's out there and life is unfair and
you're not always going to get what you
want and you're just going to have to
deal with it
if more people sorry well i was going to
say that if more people were to come to
that realization that they would just
have to get on with things and just
accept them as as to how they are well
it'd be a lot simpler wouldn't it what
do you mean by that
well if if one if if you know the
average female out there who is after
you know gig alpha chad realizes that
she can't actually attain giga alpha
chad and she may in fact have to go with
um you know stormy norman as an example
or joey bag of doughnuts
you should have uh should have a
romantic partner
but it's that notion of settling being
the boss [ __ ] which comes into conflict
with it
that what she's told and what she may
necessarily need are two different
things so such a tough pill to swallow
man and increasingly as i've spent more
time with this
i do feel for women as well um you know
it's easy i think in this situation when
we're talking about stuff like this to
men are the obvious victims of this
because they're not the ones that are
choosing to not be in relationships
they're often
on average they're the ones that are
being overlooked uh for being in
relationships uh but the experience
isn't that much better for women either
women didn't choose to have a
hypergamous nature they didn't choose to
fundamentally find attraction in
men who are across and above their
dominance hierarchy and as you put it in
one of your articles it's very difficult
to date up and across a dominance
hierarchy if you stand atop your own and
as women begin to rise up through theirs
as they become better educated they
become richer they have more status and
you now have a culture which is
encouraging women to value that
i mean you talk about another set of
stats you had was there's a 50
increase in the use of erectile
dysfunction medication amongst men who
are in a relationship with women who out
earn make more money yes correct so you
have all of these dynamics that are
bearing out that's that's got sweet [ __ ]
all to do with culture that is
exclusively physiological right
what is
what what is the the function that's
occurring that causes a man who's in a
relationship where his wife out earns
him to need to use erectile dysfunction
medication you have significantly higher
rates of divorce
i've thought about that and i i the
answer again is i think is a difficult
one because it could be one of two
things so the first thing could be that
he probably feels inadequate he doesn't
feel as though he's leading the
relationship and so he's sort of put in
a position where because he's not the
primary breadwinner he's sort of a you
know there's a reduction in serotonin
for example and he just feels inadequate
and so that translates to his ability to
actually perform in the bedroom but it
could also be a reverse causality thing
where his and his inability to actually
make money in the first place
actually
the selection effect
yes yes so it could be the case that he
was actually unable to make money for a
variety of different reasons maybe he
was just completely agreeable and so you
know that probably relates to his
inability to actually get it up so he
wasn't actually you know
it wasn't the case that he was
predisposed to get it up in the in the
first place because of a variety of
characteristics inherent to him
[Music]
wasn't there a stat
around is it 30 of women said that they
wouldn't get into a relationship with a
man that doesn't have a job
or was it the 30 that said that it was a
man that wouldn't earn more than them i
can't remember uh so there are a number
of statistics here so
these studies go back to 1939
where they found that
women were twice as likely as men to
want a partner that made more than them
or made a significant amount of money
and this sort of finding has been
replicated in studies in the 1940s 50s
60s 70s 80s
and i think the study that you're
referring to specifically
was that the
i think it may have been was it pew pew
put out a study that said that 78 of
women would not date a partner or not
get with a a prospective mate that did
not make more than they did and only 48
of men shared that uh view
[ __ ] man
and you know
no sorry go ahead
you have an ever
increasing group of high performing
women competing for an ever decreasing
group of ultra high performing men
and the choice is the analogy that i
always use is it's the same as being the
tall girlfriend
now if you're a six foot one without
heels on woman
you're looking at professional athletes
because on average women want to date a
man that is about 21 centimeters taller
than her
yes that's another uh yes
statistic
interestingly men prefer to date a woman
that's i think 16 centimeters or 12
centimeters shorter than him so even in
that and this is this is such a perfect
example right
women want them uh to date a man on
average that's 21 centimeters taller men
on average want to date a woman that is
16 centimeters shorter
in that we have a disparity we have the
preference of a man and the preference
of a woman both moving in opposite
directions but not marrying up
yes yes so the the
the missing point here is not just the
preference of a woman because from from
the conversation we're having we're
discussing female mate preferences but
what is loss here are male mate
preferences what they're looking for in
a perspective made so we talk about what
we haven't even spoken about that yeah
men don't matter
but but even looking at what men desire
in a partner
they're you know there's that notion
that there's a new 18 year old every day
and so these women that are achieving uh
quite a bit you know economically
speaking educationally speaking are
going to be on average much older than
women just entering the bloom of their
life so they're competing against
women who are on average more attracted
or more attractive to males because if
it is the case that men are attracted to
youth and fertility you're down you're
behind the eighth ball if if you're 35
with a phd
competing against an 18 year old an 18
year old that is just
doesn't
hasn't had that much life experience but
is quite attractive to
works at starbucks but she's fertile as
[ __ ]
exactly
exactly it's it's it's a tough sell it's
it's a
horribly unfair
dynamic
the asymmetries go all the way down man
i mean you said so here's another thing
that some of the girls that are
listening
may have realized
if
being smart
and rich and high status is negatively
correlated with men being attracted to
you and with success in relationships
that may lead some women to signal that
they are less smart and less educated
and less wealthy than they are and i
think that
you found a study that
showed
women under reporting their education
level in certain circumstances when
around men
this is correct so this is referencing i
believe a
a harvard um
business school study so looking at um
declarations of of um
personal success so wanting to become
something later on down the line and
when it was the case that uh women could
confidentially report their their
ambitions they would do so honestly but
when it was known that people would
actually realize or recognize them
they would actually tamp down their
ambitions so as to not make it seem as
though they were ambitious
and it logically links the fact that
they'd be less attractive to a man
because she was a boss [ __ ] career
career woman
it's uh jordan peterson
ism to say is it for every standard
deviation that a woman uh goes above the
normal iq
yes uh point that she's 30 less likely
to get married i can state the exact
statistics so uh it was a study
conducted by four universities here in
the uk
and it was found that for every 16-point
increase for a man in iq his prospect of
marriage increases by 35 percent but for
every 16 point increase in a woman's iq
her prospect of marriage decreases by 40
percent
what do you do about that
what do you do about that statistic
i i don't know that you do anything
about it again it's
all of what we're discussing here are
just
inherent facts of the human condition
about dating sexual dynamics and all of
this is premised on on evolutionary
precepts and there i don't think there's
anything you can do about it
i don't think there's anything you can
do about it as sad as that sounds unless
you want to settle
because it's almost like you'd have to
if you're a female and i do feel for
young girls particularly if i have a
daughter
in the future i definitely would feel
for her because that you have ambitions
and you want to be something and you
want to be someone you want to achieve
all these things and make quite a bit of
money good for you you should aim for
that sort of thing but it comes with the
consequence of knowing that men that you
are looking to get with in a long-term
relationship aren't interested in those
things
and
you're not going to be as attractive as
again the 18 year old
it's a difficult thing that
competence in many domains is not
something which is seen as attractive by
the sex that you're trying to attract as
a woman and also actually can be
detrimental
that you being competent working hard to
get a job to
grow a career to get status to earn
money to become educated all of these
things are actually making it more
difficult for you to do it and on top of
that they use up the single most
important resource and the most
attractive quality you have which is
time and your use yes you spend your 20s
getting educated
building up your career and earning
money to find out that men don't care
about your education level your career
or your wealth and now you're so you're
older than some women who you're now
trying to compete with that's
it's not kicking the balls uh it's a
kick in there's something else about
that's like a punch of the tits it's a
punch in the tit it's a punch in the tit
you're correct
um
ah [ __ ] man this this
entire subject area fascinates me
because of how uncomfortable it is
um
you know
we are bound by our evolutionary
precepts as you call them to just
and and the final thing as well is like
the fundamental choice that you have
left as a woman
is to
as most women on average
if this hypergamous nature ends up
continuing and if the uh how would you
say the
over success of women continues to
accelerate
uh is you have two choices as far as i
can see one of them is to
move through life and be single and the
other one is to settle with a mate that
you are fundamentally unattracted to
neither of those seem like particularly
good situations the only advantage that
women have over men in this you know
average value women and average value
men the only advantage that the women
have is the fact that they can settle
and the men don't even have that
opportunity
it's it's a tough pill to swallow but
the worst part about it is that it's not
that it's it's a reality and it it will
most likely move to being more palatable
as time goes on at least that's my
contention what do you mean it's the
fact well it's
in the sense that it the worst part
about it is that we don't know about it
that's the worst part about it is that
it's it's it's silly the shark in the
waters right it's jaws and is that it
this is a creeping
disaster that is is on the frontier that
no one is particularly informed about
and the whole point of this article was
to or these set of articles was to ring
an alarm bell to say that this is
definitely an issue that we need to be
taking a very close look at because it's
not just that it's an issue that can be
that is
that damages an economy for example it
might damage an economy but it's it's an
issue that damages the society and
long-term civilization yeah civilization
yes civilization ending
one potential remedy so i know that we
can't reprogram our sexual desires i
know that hypergamy's gonna stick about
i know that it's going to be
so unpalatable as to make it a moot
point to suggest that women should
either be held back or should choose to
hold themselves back from achievement
because it's negatively correlated with
mate success um
one thing that you could do a remedy
that you could find that would keep
everybody fine would be to reinvigorate
uh a goal of nuclear family and of uh
child rearing and of sort of more
traditional like conservative values
because that means that nobody loses out
but everybody now places the value of
having a family so high that both men
and women begin to work together
collaboratively you're not referring to
enforced monogamy by any chance are you
i'm not referring to enforced monogamy
because jordan jordan nearly got
cancelled for that and i'm not going to
that's a cancellable offense my friend
correct yes
but no to take your point seriously you
you are you are entirely correct is that
having conversations with people about
this particular topic about what is the
solution that is the the solution that
is often presented a reinvigoration of
marriage and
maybe we don't use the term enforced
monogamy but taking
marriage seriously
instead of that you would be able to say
not enticed monogamy but celebrated
monogamy
you know because people desire what they
think other people desire and
the best enforcement mechanism is
admiration and desire and social uh
renown
you know if it's now the cool thing
to have a family to have a secure life
to you know the two dogs two kids white
picket fans [ __ ]
then you don't need to mandate [ __ ]
people are just gonna do it because they
want to to do it because other people
want to do it
yeah it's memetic exactly that i mean if
if that is what is desired by
most people or perceived to be desired
by most people it's likely the case that
everyone else is probably going to want
it i mean this is memetic desire 101
right this is rene gerard in a nutshell
and but that has to do with mori's
cultural mores and
perceptions and beliefs within society
what it is that we we prioritize and it
seems at this point in time that we
don't necessarily prioritize
having a stable and healthy relationship
having a stable and healthy marriage
raising children and having to deal with
the trials and tribulations that come
with being a part of a family and being
a part of of a healthy marriage i mean
i'll talk to some friends about this and
um you know they'll say to me you know i
don't want to stay up you know change
diapers or wash dishes or do this and
that and you know take take the
necessary blows that are required to
actually maintain a healthy relationship
and well those are the things that you
have to do
if you want to maintain a healthy
relationship it requires a bit of pain
but ultimately you know that the pain
revolver results in some form of reward
or gratification
that being a healthy and happy family
and to an extent a healthy and happy
society potentially
we've thrown so much [ __ ] out of the
window that we shouldn't have done man
absolutely absolutely not not just in
terms of of marriage but probably in
terms of religiosity as well
i would say
[ __ ] babies and bath waters right oh
dude the bath's gone like the
everything's gone out of the window and
uh
this is why this is why i find it
i find it so difficult now
the the liberal impulses and the
progressive impulses that i have in me
i find them getting dampened down by
increasing wisdom that i find in the
past
um
and that's a would you say like i know
an internal struggle that i'm dealing
with at the moment where i'm just so
tentative about whatever the next piece
of progression is because i'm like well
what if we what if we throw away yet
another thing that we desperately needed
but we didn't know about yes well the
notion about progressivism i find
interesting and we don't necessarily
have to have a discussion about politics
is that
where are we progressive too just
because you're progressing doesn't mean
you're progressing in the right
direction you could be regressing in
fact if you're throwing out um
ideas and concepts and institutions that
are are long held and vitally important
to the society or to
survival of families and societies
you're probably going in the wrong
direction
i don't know i don't know it's a
some sort of cultural revolution like
that i think would be a a pretty cool
thing we were talking before we got
started about the fact that you have a
red pill for men that only takes you up
to the point at which you [ __ ] a girl
and then it goes away and you have uh i
think it's like the pink pill or women's
dating uh like subreddits and and stuff
um that is basically the same thing for
women but there's no equivalent learning
using the
understandings of evolutionary
psychology to encourage ineffective and
foster a successful marriage and then
family life moving forward like
it's just it's a huge
huge problem swimming underneath the
water that most people don't know about
that the culture is actively working to
pull us away from
yeah and now it's being reinforced it's
feeding the most base elements of our uh
it's limitlessly hijacking us in the in
the worst way possible and taking us
further and further away from a
destination which is not only good for
individual flourishing but also good for
civilizational flourishing as
well completely correct and maybe the
reason why that is is that it doesn't
sell it's not sexy enough
it's not medically pleasing
to want a family per se into to you know
the 2.5 kids or whatever it is in a
white picket fence it's just not
something that is that is encouraged to
for people to want
they'd much rather you know engage in
hookup culture you know do what you like
right but understand that there are
consequences to actions i think that
that's probably the the fundamental
lesson here is that actions have
consequences and you have to you're
gonna have to bear those consequences
but the single biggest predictor for
extramarital sex is premarital sex
premium sex correct correct and one of
the biggest uh points of of um or
factors that that lead to divorce is
exactly that is the amount of of um
of sexual partners you had prior to
marriage
with that and economics i've got some
friends who are absolutely [ __ ] i've
got some friends who are not going to be
able to help
i just have a conversation with them
well done in marriage at all dude stop
it stop it i know i know that you're not
thinking about this you're 25 and full
of testosterone and just sleeping with
anything that moves but i promise you in
in 25 years time when you're itching
gripping onto the bed sheets in the
middle of the night because you're so
torn uh you're going to thank me
testosterone is a hell of a thing
because you know as a criminologist we
it's fascinating when we look at the
rates of of crime commission between
between the ages of 15 and 25 is that's
when most guys will commit the vast
majority of crime and then it sort of
tapers off beyond the age of 25 and it's
because of testosterone right your
testosterone typically decreases at the
age of 26.
why is it the case that people who are
on trt which is
supraphysiological levels of
testosterone aren't committing terms of
crime then or are they
i don't know i don't know that if that's
uh that's a great question for a
criminologist to answer i think the
reason why that is is that men that
typically take trt are probably in their
40s maybe their late 30s and they
already have a career in a family and so
that is one of the main uh or several
main factors that would prevent you from
engaging in crimes having a stable
family and
a stable livelihood and so you don't
want to to destroy any of that by
engaging in crime
so what we don't want
is a big bunch of roving bands of incels
who are all on trt in their 40s
jacked out of their minds with huge
foreign kids yeah yeah definitely that i
mean
i i do worry about that though
particularly the the rise in insult them
and the effect is going to have on crime
because we could probably talk about
crime statistics around this and the
sort of things we're seeing uh at the
fringes in terms of in cells engaging in
crime
and all the indicators would
would tell me that there is going to be
a looming crisis with regard to this
it may not be as serious as as let's say
you know rapid drug dealing for example
but it is going to be an increasing
problem moving forward do you think that
incels should be considered a terrorist
group
oh that's a good question i i don't want
to wait into that one because
that's all that's well i will give you
an answer it's not that i'm i'm afraid
of providing an answer it's
there has to be an ideological opponent
uh component that is attached to whether
or not a group is is labeled as an
in-cell or excuse me as a terrorist and
uh is it an ideology maybe maybe i i
i'll have to give more thought to that i
don't quite know the answer to the
question it's a good question uh
nama kate who does the i think it's the
incel podcast or the black pill podcast
and um it was briefly after that guy in
plymouth or portsmouth that um went on a
shooting rampage and he was associated
with some incel black pill forums and
they started calling it a terrorist
attack and yes
it may have a backfiring effect actually
thinking about it now because this you
have to imagine that this demographic of
people is already downtrodden to begin
with and further labeling them as
terrorists may actually metastasize uh
further thermal activity
they actually
this is the thing that the press and the
media and government needs to understand
that
it is not a
it's no longer the case that the media
are just a broadcast platform
they are it's a two-way street whereby
they actually influence the behavior of
people on the ground so i had uh
andrew gold on the show and he
was part way through a documentary
series about non-offending pedophiles in
germany so i think that
yeah they call they call themselves
pedophiles and they call the group that
um act on their impulses pedo criminals
uh and that's the bifurcation i think
we've seen a minor
attracted person now map
as the uh
academically very strange academically
justified or
labeled term so
he was talking to them and he said that
there's three main risks that these
pedophiles not the criminals that they
suffer with uh one of them's being
intoxicated the second one is proximity
to children and the third is
ostracization by society
and he says it become it's like a
reverse self-fulfilling prophecy if you
want to push me away so much and you say
that there is no place for me in this
society i'm reprehensible and i'm
disgusting and i'm terrible and i've not
got any future at all
why should i play your game why should i
play by your rules
why should i why shouldn't i go and
shoot up a school if i'm an insult that
doesn't feel like he's got any culture
any future
why shouldn't i do that um yes
absolutely correct
this is a massive issue and
look
for me
when it comes to public policy we don't
really think clearly about the negative
externalities of the of these policies
when it comes to actually putting forth
good policy one has to think clearly
about what the consequences are the
benefits and the consequences and the
economist thomas saul thomas soul said
that
public policy is not
you implement something and it's
immediately fixed it's actually a
trade-off you're giving up something to
get something else and so whenever a
policy is implemented you have to think
very critically about the effects not
only in the short term but in the long
term think not just about a c and b but
that but the rest of the letters in the
alphabet when it comes to probable
outcomes
[ __ ] man well i mean
i don't know i don't know this this
for all that it's post-apocalyptic and
makes me terrified to my back teeth
about what's gonna happen in future it's
endlessly fascinating i really
appreciate the work that you do and for
guiding me through this uh this little
back and forth today what have you got
coming up have you got any ideas about
areas that you're interested in for
writing next
great question i
i'm of two minds on it because i'm i am
interested in returning to wool
capitalism and looking at hollywood and
whether or not
woke messaging in films actually reduces
the amount of viewership and the revenue
that is earned by movies it might be
interesting to look at but i'm slowly
moving away from
from writing from uh writing as sort of
a public intellectual and i'm sort of
going into in the direction of finance
and industry of uh doing my own thing on
the side because i don't i don't want
fame i don't want to be to be seen i
don't tweet at all and i will as you
pointed out at the the outset of this i
will
publish your paper every two three four
months and granted it takes a lot of
work to actually write these [ __ ]
papers like good god it takes months to
actually research them it's like an
academic paper
but it's it's um it's slowly becoming
a time constraint and a strict
constraint to my cognitive capital is
that i could be doing things which are
more productive and beneficial to people
as opposed to simply writing papers
well from one reader that has at least
found a little bit of joy in the stuff
that you've put out man i think you know
whether whether this is close to the
the twilight of your writing career or
not i think you've you've put some
awesome stuff out there and it's really
really interested me so yeah i hope
you've got a few more left in the tank
and then we've got an excuse to do this
again
i really appreciate it chris and thank
you for having me on the podcast it was
a fantastic conversation i should
actually thank rob henderson that son of
a [ __ ] has bought me a cigar and it's
probably waiting for me back in the
house go smoke it but i'm gonna thank
him because he's actually uh he i was
actually hesitant because i don't really
do podcasts but he said chris is a great
guy you gotta talk to him i trust him
he's one of the dude bros and i uh
i'm a bit of a dude bro myself to be
honest so i guess we uh
yeah we got on well i've got that asian
seal of approval man that's all i'm here
for that half asian age of their um
approval is the joke that we we make
half asian rob henderson
have asian yes have asian rob i love it
dude catch you next time wonderful buddy
take care all best what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace